so David you do admit that UFOs exist
well what does UFO mean it means
unidentified flying object it's
different than intelligent alien species
from another country and yet another one
of these UFOs has been shot down by the
United States increasingly the question
is what exactly are these the latest
claim is they are in the balloon
category generally similar to that first
surveillance balloon believed to be from
China that was shot down off the coast
of South Carolina but not exactly the
same and it is still early days and we
are trying to gather information so
let's go to what we know and what took
place CNN reporting on Saturday U.S jet
shoots down unidentified object over
Northern Canada
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
said Saturday an unidentified object had
been shot down by a U.S fighter jet over
Canadian airspace on his orders I
ordered the takedown of an unidentified
object that violated Canadian airspace
NORAD command shot down the object over
the Yukon Canadian and U.S aircraft were
scrambled and a usf-22 successfully
fired at the object the object is being
described as cylindrical and smaller
than the suspected Chinese balloon shot
down last weekend according to Canadian
defense minister anina Anand
later Saturday the White House confirmed
Trudeau and Joe Biden authorized the
shoot down and the Pentagon said the
object was first spotted over Alaska on
Friday evening immediately questions
about was this the same thing or not was
it in the category is ballooned the
right word here is what Senator Chuck
Schumer said after being briefed by
National Security adviser Jake Sullivan
until they get that comprehensive
analysis however we have to look at each
balloon individually
they believe they were yes but much
smaller than the uh than the one the
first one both of those one over Canada
one over Alaska were 40 000 feet
immediately it was determined that
that's a danger to commercial aircraft
yeah so um there are sort of conspiracy
types who are saying wait a second
cylindrical object is very different
than balloon soon everybody is lying to
us right now I have no reason in
particular to think anybody is lying to
us but we do need more information of
course we also have now been presented
with the claim from China that the
United States has done the exact same
thing 10 times there is a CNN article
from this morning China accuses U.S of
illegally flying balloons across its
airspace China has accused the U.S of
illegally flying a high altitude
balloons into its airspace more than 10
times since January 2022 claims that
Drew an immediate rebuttal from the
White House will hear that rebuttal in a
moment
as bilateral tensions flare in the
Fallout from the Chinese balloon that
was shot down by American fighter jets
after traveling across the continental
U.S let's look at a clip here of the
National Security council's John Kirby
very clearly just denying that the U.S
does the same thing take a listen
and I believe we have the clip here
do we have the clip let's see
I love having Clips Jing just in the
last hour or two the four Ministry there
has accused the United States since the
start of 2022 of flying balloons 10
different times over Chinese airspace
can you respond to that accusation not
true not doing it just absolutely not
true so the U.S let me just push you a
little further that so the U.S is not
using these balloons Technologies at all
over China
that is right we are not flying balloons
uh over China that is absolutely true
Now understand
whenever such a statement is made
in colloquial language we would say this
is a complete denial
if you want to play these cynical games
which are very often accurate right I
mean we we call them games but there's a
reason we play them
when he's there's a couple critical
words there balloons and over China his
statement and I hate that this is the
way stuff is communicated these days I
am not arguing that such a thing is or
isn't taking place his statement is
balloons aren't being flown over China
could balloons be flown off the coast of
China and he wouldn't be lying yeah
could there be something other than a
balloon flown over China and he wouldn't
be lying yeah so again you always want
to pay really close attention to the
language that's being used I'm not
suggesting one thing or the other we're
just kind of parsing through it okay and
then lastly then just as will there be
this will that Viewpoint be expressed
directly to Beijing Beyond here on the
friendly confines of Morning Joe uh when
when do the next conversation start
between Washington and Beijing over a
matter that's clearly inflaming tensions
between the two countries well two
points there Jonathan first of all we
still have diplomatic relations with
China we still have an embassy there
it's not like all Communications between
us and the PRC have shut down obviously
there are certain Vehicles like military
to military vehicles which are not open
to us right now and that's unfortunate
but we do have the ability to
communicate directly with the Chinese
leaders and we have okay so relations
are still ongoing although Kirby says we
are absolutely not doing the same thing
so a couple different things going on
here number one uh do we do we want to
and should we figure out what exactly
these um uh unidentified flying objects
are of course we should is it likely
that at this point official sources know
more than they are saying publicly
absolutely is it likely that the U.S is
doing equivalent surveillance in China
to what China is doing in the U.S of
course it might just take different
forms this is what countries do it
applies to Russia it applies to many
different countries and lastly at this
time do you have any reason to believe
that these are intelligent aliens we do
not and of course I am mathematically
and statistically open to the
possibility of intelligent life out
there in the universe do I believe it is
this these these objects that represent
that I have no reason whatsoever to
believe that that's the case solar power
is suddenly awesome on Fox news now that
these Chinese balloons are being
asserted without evidence to have
extraordinarily Advanced solar power
capabilities this is so fun these Fox
News people are so predictable and and
it's so funny in a way if it weren't so
sad once again Fox News propagandist
Maria Bartiromo is starting to talk
about solar panels and in the context of
the Chinese balloons she again brought
up this is now the second weekend in a
row that Maria brings up they are
getting unlimited power from these solar
panels they have unlimited energy
wow if if now solar panels represent not
some woke distraction from burning
fossil fuels but rather unlimited energy
seems like we should be taking solar
more seriously in the U.S don't you
think here's Maria Bartiromo yesterday
saloons the largest one that you know
you could fit three buses in it that was
shot down over South Carolina last
Saturday that balloon was able to snap
images of our military installations and
send them back to China in live time so
what John Radcliffe told us last week
was spot on they were using solar panels
for unlimited power unlimited energy to
continue the surveillance program damn
those solar panels they're getting the
best of us because they're so awesome
unlimited power it's crazy what about
clouds like Trump said what about night
time like Trump said all of a sudden
solar power the Holy Grail of
surveillance and spying and remember
last weekend she uh proposed something
similar there's China did it drop and
for surveillance products powered by
solar energy to allow unlimited
surveillance yeah without any evidence
whatsoever Maria suggesting you know
when they popped the balloon when Biden
popped the balloon it might have
released
micro surveillance elements powered by
the sun which could in perpetuity
surveil the United States wow it's
amazing such technology even exists with
solar power Maria so solar power sounds
pretty damn awesome now if you watch
Maria bartiromo's program according to
Fox News it sounds like solar energy is
really the way to go so of course we're
sort of being tongue-in-cheek here sort
of being facetious it would be great for
them to just take solar panels and solar
power
10 as seriously as they are taking it
now in general rather than doing their
normal stuff it's not sunny enough in
the United States for solar which would
never work oh but what about when it's
cloudy out there but we just don't know
just take it 10 as seriously as you're
taking it now and we would all be way
better off you truly cannot write this
stuff another Republican I'm not talking
now about George Anthony devolder Santos
I'm talking about a different Republican
who claimed Jewish Heritage and it turns
out she's not only lying
her grandfather was a Nazi uh I it's it
what a world that we live in article
from the Jerusalem Post
congresswoman claims to be Jewish
revealed to be the granddaughter of a
Nazi we are talking about new Republican
congresswoman Anna Paulina Luna
she has claimed Jewish Heritage
previously and it turns out her
grandfather Heinrich mayerhoffer and
this is not the this is not like a jack
Maya Hoffer moment the when Bill
O'Reilly got pranked by that this is
genuinely the guy's name Heinrich
mayerhoffer who died in 2003 served in
the armed forces of Nazi Germany when he
was a teenager in the 40s you really
should read this entire J Post article
it's wild wild stuff Florida Republican
congresswoman Anna Paulina Luna was
outed by The Washington Post Friday for
lying about her Jewish Heritage in a
previous interview with the Jewish
Insider not only is Luna almost
certainly not Jewish but according to
several family members according to the
post Luna's paternal grandfather
Heinrich mayerhoffer who died in 2003
served in the armed forces of Nazi
Germany as a teenager in the 40s Luna
had told the Jewish Insider I was raised
as a Messianic Jew by my father
clarifying she identifies as a Christian
I am also a small fraction Nazi now
she's speaking ethnically of course
The Insider had interviewed Luna in
reaction to the fact that Marjorie
Taylor Green known for her Jewish space
laser conspiracy endorsed Luna's
candidacy if she were anti-semitic asked
Luna after claiming Ashkenazi Roots why
did she endorse me
I in no way shape or form would ever put
myself in a position where I'm hanging
out with someone like that and so I just
don't see that Marjorie Taylor green is
that person if I see it happening on the
right I'm the first person to condemn it
and say like hey that's not cool I don't
align with that reminiscent of Hillary
Clinton's I told Wall Street to cut it
out which they laughed about but now
this is taken seriously Luna has also
invoked Nazis in her political rhetoric
in 2021 she tweeted a video insinuating
that a registry of Americans who were
not vaccinated against covid would be
like the Nazi list of Jews
um this is very very quickly becoming
another George Santos situation as the
lies are piling up now some people wrote
to me and said David you know sure she's
a liar but like what's so bad about
saying you're one religion when you're
just not that religion like David if you
said you were Baptist and you weren't
Baptist it wouldn't really be offensive
it would be a lie but it would be
offensive it wouldn't be offensive you
really have to understand what Judaism
is
being Jewish is not just a religion
Judaism is a cultural identity if you
were if you didn't convert into Judaism
you're also ethnically Jewish like when
I did my DNA I came back oh David you're
Ashkenazi that's an ethnicity I could
change my beliefs into whatever
Mormonism I'd still be ethnically Jewish
and there's a history ethnically and
culturally in addition to religiously
which has faced centuries of persecution
really Millennia it's an ethno-religious
group and so when you falsely claim
Jewish Heritage you're not only erasing
the experiences and the struggles of
actual Jewish people you also perpetuate
stereotypes you're participating in
cultural appropriation so it's not like
a harmless act it is deception it is a
lie at the end of the day but it's a
particular type of lie that under
undermines trust and respect so George
Santos George Anthony devolder Santos
did this falsely claiming Jewish
Heritage Anna Paulina Luna has done it
and then lastly there's one other
wrinkle here
pretending to be Jewish and then
exonerating Marjorie Taylor green
ferment accusations of anti-Semitism
with your fake jewishness is like
another particularly disgusting layer to
the entire thing so it is not only
Santos that is participating in these
and many other lies if you're curious
about Luna's other lies there's a number
of articles about it now which you can
find
ugly ugly stuff we're going to take a
very quick break make sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube channel make
sure you're subscribed to the Spanish
YouTube channel what what David what are
you talking about later on in the show
I'll tell you all about what's going on
in Spanish
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
there's something different about the
David packman show as compared to many
of the shows you might see from
corporate media which is that we are
actually primarily funded by our
audience and we try to make it really
easy for our audience to support us you
can make a pledge on patreon you can
become a YouTube member you can support
us on Twitch during live streams all
these different ways the best way the
simplest way the most direct way where
we keep keep the largest share of every
dollar that is contributed is through
our website memberships you can sign up
at joinpakman.com the perks are
straightforward we do an extra show for
all of our members and you also get our
daily show earlier and commercial free
and most recently you also get a sound
board that mimics my soundboard Obama
you know it truth Central at man's a
loser we have a soundboard like that
available to our members you can sign up
at joinpakman.com I look forward to
welcoming you into the membership ranks
well folks it's the Trump laptop yeah
it's you know with all of these things
it eventually comes back around and
really bites Republicans we are now
aware of a laptop uh belonging to a
trump Aid
that contains on it
classified documents I know I know but
what about Hunter Biden what about
Hunter Biden this is really unbelievable
CNN reports that the Trump team has
turned over additional classified
records and a laptop to Federal
prosecutors wow wow
um the Trump attorneys also handed over
an empty folder marked classified
evening briefing these are additional
handovers understand still related to
what took place in December and January
and it suggests CNN writes that the
protracted effort by the justice
department from to repossess records
from Trump's presidency may not be done
a trump aide previously copied some
pages of these classified documents onto
a thumb drive
and a laptop not realizing they were
classified according to sources the
laptop which belonged to an aide who
works for Save America pack that's
Trump's scam pack and the thumb drive
were also given to investigators in
January
special counsel Jack Smith's
investigation which is pursuing criminal
charges possible criminal charges
subpoenaed Trump last May for all of
this stuff folks there's a laptop okay
it is not surprising necessarily but in
a sense it is still shocking that after
year after year in year out year and
year out Hillary's server Hunter Biden's
laptop we now discover that Trump had
people working for him
involved in the mishandling of
classified information which we knew
already but now we even introduce a
laptop element into it we need that
laptop we need that laptop and former
former Federal prosecutor Sean Wu was
interviewed by Jim Acosta on CNN
recently he said that laptop's got to be
a part of this investigation listen to
this turned over uh even more of these
classified materials uh a laptop has
also come into the picture here to
Federal prosecutors in recent months it
really underscores the enormous
difference between what's going on with
Biden's documents and pences first of
all volume of documents but the fact
that they're still finding more and the
fact that's on the laptop is a huge
security concern for that so it really
underscores why you really need a
criminal investigation of that some
questions in my mind still about why
special counsel appointed to provide and
how come still have one for Pence and
the laptop is a concern because
who knows well not only it's a concern
that was downloaded any classified
information sent some information
downloaded onto the laptop from there
it's easily transmitted it could be
copied to other electronic devices as
well so that's very different than if
you could say hey it's inside a room at
least we know where to document the
paper document was but once it goes
electronic it can go anyplace yeah now
there's another element to this as well
as I mentioned the laptop belongs
belonged to someone who worked for the
save America pack those aren't in in a
sense those aren't even political arms
in the operational sense we're talking
about a pack which just distributes
money that is raised and figures out
ways in Trump's case to funnel that
money back into his friends and family
and family members so that is not even
someone in the universe who of people
who even hyper pathetically should be
reading classified documents so the
question we're quickly coming to and I
know many of you are frustrated and
you've been sending me emails
when is Trump getting indicted if at all
and I continue to say I don't have any
idea you may all remember that for a
period of years I came to you and I was
almost in tears quite frankly saying
Trump's not going to be indicted I don't
expect any indictment whatsoever and if
he's indicted he's not going to see a
day of jail time or prison time I admit
that in the aftermath of the search
warrant being executed at Mar-A-Lago my
view shifted us to the likelihood of an
indictment and I thought oh an
indictment seems more likely at this
point but I still maintain that Trump is
not going to see any jail time any
prison time even in the most extreme
hypothetical where Trump is convicted
and sentenced it would either be a
suspended sentence or a sentence to be
lived out at his home and that is
thinking so many years ahead quite
frankly
I am now going sort of back to where I
was previously
I just don't know that an indictment is
coming I really don't and ultimately if
either way whatever consequences there
are are going to be minor and symbolic
in nature does it even matter I do think
it matters I actually think indicting a
former president would be a big big deal
it also could really throw the campaign
into further disarray which would be
great to see and we'll talk about how
that campaign is going a little later
but I share the frustration I don't know
that an indictment is actually coming at
the same time Trump might be indicted
tomorrow it's extraordinarily unclear
and in addition to that there are so
many different investigations which
could lead to an indictment that it's
very hard to know what's going on I
think the best approach is wait and see
live your life and if Trump's indicted
we will all know and we will assess from
there I have something really good to
show you Dan Goldman is a new
Congressman on the Democratic side this
guy is a major asset to the Democratic
party he confronted Republican
Congressman Jim Jordan during this
weaponization committee Republicans when
they took control house created all of
these bogus committees we're going to do
a Twitter committee to look into big
Tech we're going to do a weaponization
of government committee to look into the
FBI and all these different things Jim
Jordan during these hearings has
offhandedly been mentioning that there
are dozens of whistleblowers who are who
know the truth about what went on
uh Dan Goldman who's an attorney
actually confronts Jim Jordan and says
are there notes about these
whistleblowers when will you give us the
information about these whistleblowers
and look at how quickly and easily Jim
Jordan is Tangled Up into a rhetorical
pretzel this is so devastating the way
that Goldman schools Jordan here is
brutal and I don't know why Jordan would
have expected anything else from a
former Federal prosecutor an actual
prosecutor let's Dive Right into this
this is gold on providing that to the
minority the point is it wasn't special
so much it became the norm with that the
chair down you can have a point of order
um has there been a lot of mention of uh
information and testimony that you all
have received from whistleblowers when
are you planning on providing that to
the minority you could have been for the
very first deposition or excuse me
transcribed interview The Whistleblower
I was there when he testified on Tuesday
okay that's fine I assume you'll turn
those over but what about you you talk
about got dozens of whistleblowers when
are we going to get that information
remember dozens means at least 24.
you're talking about at least two dozen
when they testify when when we work with
I'll work with the ranking memory on
that if you don't have any uh
transcriptions of their interviews we
have the first one and we have the
dozens who come and talk to our office
they talk to your office privately I
talk to Republican staff right
and they're not transcribed no notes no
nothing first one happened Tuesday no no
I'm not talking about the first one the
next one happens tomorrow the third one
happens next Wednesday and we'll
continue to do that you just said dozens
or you do have notes from those or
they're just talking to you yeah at the
rate at which Jordan's saying they're
going to be talking to people you're
talking about a year before you hear
from dozens chairman isn't isn't that
how whistleblowers typically work well
it's how they're supposed to work it's
not how they worked in the in the
impeachment that Mr Goldman was a part
of when that goes into ad hominem's Mr
ship said he didn't have contact with
that whistleblower it worked exactly
appropriately until Mr dangers would not
allow we're doing it the way we were
supposed to do it Mr Goldman no you're
supposed to turn it over to the minority
when they when they have when they come
and testify you you'll have access to
the transcript like and understand what
Jordan so the point that Goldman is
making is inquiring as to whether these
dozens of whistleblowers really exists
because they keep being mentioned in
passing and what Jordan wants to focus
on is you'll hear from them when they
come and testify but of course
both sides have people on the committee
both sides get to ask Witnesses
questions in order for the Democrats on
the committee to be ready to
meaningfully uh inquire of these
supposedly dozens of whistleblowers they
need information about them they don't
even have names understand that and
that'll that'll be mentioned in a moment
Jim Jordan keeps saying well you'll get
information when they testify and
Goldman says but where are the notes
where's the information so we can
prepare the implication of course is
these dozens of whistleblowers simply
don't exist everyone on the committee
will you mean your staff is not going to
turn it over to our staff we're just in
the dark now when the transcript is done
you will get the transcript I mean of
other dozens of whistleblowers you have
already talked to that came to talk to
your staff supposedly yeah what do you
want me to turn over there
Jim are the whistleblowers in the room
with us right now can you see them here
uh did you do their names
notes did anyone take notes I'll be
happy to talk with the ranking member on
how we handle uh that information thank
you all I'm telling you is we will
schedule each for a deposition and we're
that is not what he's talking about
doing that you didn't show up for the
first one uh but you could have been
there with that I didn't know about it
the chair now
Goldman's a really valuable asset in
this political climate he is
straightforward in his approach but he
maintains a professional demeanor he has
extraordinary attention to detail he
leaves no stone unturned in his lines of
inquiry and we all know the implication
here which is there is no evidence that
these dozens of whistleblowers exist
we're aware of one supposed
whistleblower remember also that the
right has a history over the last let's
call it in the Trump era in the last six
plus years the right as a history of
presenting someone as a whistleblower
when they're not really blowing the
whistle about anything like I could call
myself a whistleblower but then if I
show up and I basically say here's the
terms of service from Twitter and they
were being followed I'm not really
blowing the whistle on anything right
you can call me a whistleblower you can
turn on bright lights and put makeup on
me and ask me questions and say I'm a
hero and put me on Hannity or whatever
but I'm not really blowing the whistle
unless I'm actually blowing the whistle
and so do these 24 or 36 I don't know
how many dozens Jim maybe I don't know
if Jim Jordan knows what the word dozens
mean but
if these dozens of whistleblowers exist
is a real question and if people exist
who are going to be called
whistleblowers there's a real question
as whether as to whether they are
blowing the whistle about anything so
Jim Jordan is not the type of guy that
can go up against Dan Goldman Jim Jordan
should be embarrassed in this way at
every single hearing because he is a
joke and it is humiliating we'll have
the clips I played for you here on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show and on our Youtube
channel search YouTube for David Pacman
show you'll find it easily
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show there is
an absolutely brutal new poll in which
Donald Trump is losing to Ron DeSantis
by 13 in the 2024 Republican primary
let's talk about it but wait what you
you like trust polls man or what
remember that moment from my interview
with Patrick Bet David in Florida a
couple weeks ago well listen I mean
let's talk about it right when we look
at polls there are three important
questions that we ask is the pollster
highly rated and historically reliable
that's an important question second
question is this one poll dramatically
different than every other poll if you
have 20 polls 19 say one thing and one
says something else we would want to
understand why that is and is there
something in particular about the
subject matter or the timing that makes
polling on a particular issue inherently
unreliable so it's not about pollster
quality it's just about this is a really
hard thing or it's a really hard time to
be asking people about this subject
matter so let's ask that question okay a
new Monmouth poll has Donald Trump
losing to Ron DeSantis who is not even
running yet
by 13 points in a hypothetical
Republican primary that's 53 for
DeSantis to 40 for Trump now that is a
hypothetical head-to-head if you end up
having Nikki Haley run she's expected to
announce soon if you've got Mike Pompeo
Mike Pence maybe other people named Mike
or maybe some people not named Mike
you are going to have different numbers
this is a hypothetical Head to Head now
let's run through our questions is
Monmouth a good pollster the answer is
yes Monmouth is an a-rated pollster by
538 even morning consult which is often
used by corporate media it's only a
b-rated pollster uh you gov Yahoo poll
which is very much used as well is a B
plus so yes our first question Monmouth
is a good pollster is this poll an
outlier compared to others in a sense it
is okay and so we can look at 538's
recent Republican primary polls and the
results are sort of off the map uh not
often up the result the results are all
over the map and so depending on where
you look there's a primary poll from The
Economist from a few days ago that one
has Trump plus 10 but there's a lot of
undecideds there you look at a yugov
poll it has Trump up to in Trump versus
DeSantis you look at a morning consult
poll from about a week ago and that one
has Trump plus 18. so in a sense yes the
Monmouth poll is a little bit of an
outlier although you can find polling
here that does have DeSantis leading
there's a yugav Yahoo news poll which
has DeSantis plus four
um when it's asked in a different way
without other candidates head to head so
the general answer to is this an outlier
is when the polling is Trump versus
DeSantis only it does seem to be pretty
good for Ron DeSantis when the polling
includes other candidates or it doesn't
Force an answer and lets you put I don't
know haven't decided yet or whatever
then it seems to be better for Donald
Trump and then we get to the third
question I mentioned is this something
we can even really get good data on in
February of the year before the election
yes and no you know valuable polling
data
without a clear field
unclear about whether Trump is going to
get indicted unclear what Joe Biden's
next two years are going to look like
and what Republicans are going to run on
and what voters are going to want there
is a limit to how valuable today's
polling data is it doesn't mean the
polling is inaccurate based on what
Republican voters are saying right now
it's a broader question which is does
this type of poll
uh what is it 9 plus 12. 21 months
before an election well and in this
particular case more more like 17 months
before the primary is going to be of
some limited value what this polling
will do
is it will brutally trigger Donald Trump
and possibly explode this Feud Civil War
that is building between Donald Trump
and Ron DeSantis and that's what we're
going to talk about next medic attacks
so far on Florida Governor Trump's
Governor remember Trump lives in Florida
on his own Governor Ron DeSantis Donald
Trump desperate to find new ways to
attack a guy who is defeating Trump in
some polls despite the fact that Ron
DeSantis hasn't even said I'm running
for this thing he's not even a candidate
and he is ahead of trump significantly
in some polls including the most recent
Monmouth poll this genuinely has the
potential to put the 2016 Republican
party to shame in terms of how
humiliating and absurd this primary
could be Donald Trump on the heels of
this new Monmouth poll that as DeSantis
beating him by 13 which we already
talked about has posted an attack on Ron
DeSantis to his platform truth social
in which he goes after Ron DeSantis for
wearing a blue tie when he met with
Trump in the Oval Office while Trump was
President well not exactly let's take a
look at the post from truth social Trump
posting a picture where he is sitting
there with Matt Gates and DeSantis uh
and oh who is I forget who the guy is on
the right I feel so silly but I forget
who that is and Ron DeSantis is wearing
a blue tie and Donald Trump says in his
post who is that in the blue tie being
so nice to the president of the United
States while in the Oval Office now this
is not actually about the tie color this
is about Trump pointing out Ron DeSantis
who now says bad things about me used to
suck up to me
now of course to all of us who
understand how politics works
we understand that that's how politics
works you try to get close to power
uh if you're someone like Ron DeSantis
you want to go to the White House
Governors love going to the White House
so of course you're nice to Trump but
Trump simply can't help but try to find
anything to attack Santa's over recall
that last week
uh he went after DeSantis for this
picture in which DeSantis is with some
allegedly High school-aged girls who I
guess he he was teaching he was the
teacher of and Trump posted that's not
Ron is it he would never do such a thing
referring to grooming high school girls
with alcohol yeah meanwhile in addition
Trump adding to the embarrassment by
tweeting trash polls in response to the
Monmouth poll which has trumped down 13.
Trump tweeting about a premise poll if
you haven't heard of premise as a
pollster they're not even serious enough
to be raided by 538 that one has Trump
up 30 points that seems a little bit
difficult to believe and Trump also
posting a link to a Breitbart poll which
isn't even a poll it's just a
favorability poll it's not an actual
2024 poll it is all completely pathetic
and this is going to be be an insane
primary now I want to oh
I've been wanting to do this for a
little bit
I want to kind of frame the next 21
months for you
if you have read Neil postman's book
amusing ourselves to death I know many
of you are think David you're not going
to quote technopoly again are you no
this is an earlier book by Neil Postman
it's called amusing ourselves to death
Postman wrote this book in the mid 80s I
think it was in 85 and what Postman
argued was that if we're going to do a
serious analysis of television and
remember in the mid 80s things were
moving from sort of a print medium
dramatically more towards a visual
Medium television one of the things that
Neil Postman talked about is it's not
just about the content of Television
it's about the fact that television
frames all issues as having to be or
needing to be entertaining Sesame Street
which is a great program right Sesame
Street still implicitly is telling us
learning should be entertaining and it
devalues more difficult forms of
learning that aren't entertaining but
require different type of thought and
one of the things that has become true
not only in the era of Television but
you could take Neil postman's 85
analysis and make it in 2023 when it
comes to to Social and online media one
of the things that has become a reality
is that there is this expectation that
the format of how we get News Today
Twitter and uh the way TV news is
produced and online news as well okay
I'm part of this
we now believe politics should also be
entertaining debates should be
entertaining and that's why primary
debates and presidential debates have
these one-minute answers and 30 second
rebuttals 15 second rebuttals it's not
to actually learn anything about the
candidates in fact it prevents us from
learning about the candidates there are
other ways to learn about the candidates
it tells us politics should be
entertaining these things should be
entertaining and so in a sense I am part
of this
my goal is to work within the formats
that are available to reach as many
people as possible and tell them hey
there are better Ways to Think Through
who we're going to vote for and learn
and say okay so what's the point of me
telling you this one of the things that
we really have to
think about as we go from now into the
primaries and into the general election
is that to really figure out who we
should be voting for What policies would
be better for the country all these
different things you have to exit the
world of where it all needs to be
entertaining the unfortunate reality is
and we're going to talk about the
strategy later or probably tomorrow in
order to defeat Trump and this is the
point I'm building to in order to defeat
Trump Ron DeSantis has to do some of the
things Trump does well he has to be
entertaining he has to attack Trump he
has to be titillating and salacious and
Rhonda santis is going to have to figure
out how it is a horrible thing that on
the one hand we know that all of this is
terrible for the country the fact that
this is how a Republican primary is
going to be fought who can come up with
the slickest insults in the entire thing
I would love to change that I can't
change that
and so when we are thinking through how
Republicans are going to choose their
nominee Democrats to a degree the same
thing but if Biden runs they're not
really going to be choosing it's going
to be Biden it's going to come down to
who can make their campaign as
entertaining and titillating as possible
not who can propose the best policy on
Health Care not who can lay out the most
sober and sensible foreign policy it it
it doesn't make a difference what
matters is
can you compartmentalize it make it a
snippet and make it as entertaining as
possible and that is how politics is
done and it's a sad and horrible thing
and we're going to be looking at this
election through that lens I'm going to
do everything I can to really try to to
to do that because I think it has to be
done all right let's take a quick break
we have many other things to talk about
coming up in mere moments
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
ladies and gentlemen I bring you today
exciting news of medical advancement we
now have seen an individual healed from
his paralysis
merely through the prayer of a Christian
preacher this now will allow us to heal
so many people I never knew it was so
simple take a look at this incredible
video of a Christian preacher restoring
the movement and feeling in a man's
paralyzed hand and he did it on a stage
which with music playing if you can
imagine this is John okay he's an
electrician four years ago he was in a
work accident where he got completely
shocked he lost feeling in his left hand
he said today when you caught that out
earlier someone has numbness he said he
started feeling a tingling sensation in
his left hand and in prayer he said he
started moving his hand in faith he now
has mobility and feeling in his left
hand
wow it's starting to do it I feel it
tingling I think he needs more because
these fingers are not going straight yet
but I got a lot more movements let's
pray complete Miracle tonight in Jesus
name pray pray pray let this miracle be
done folks pray harder in the name of
Jesus look at that do it again that's it
are you seeing this
Lord touch them with your power let this
miracle come to pass the guy now has
fainted Lord give him that Grace but his
hand is moving perfectly even though the
guy is unconscious we need to close that
hand even now
in the name of Jesus pick him up for a
second
how shaken up about this are you right
now
um the tingling like if I just got
electrocuted again
what is that was that the wrong hand
there
was this
a mighty hand of Praise remember it's
not the preacher it's Jesus that's doing
it I genuinely hate this stuff now
sometimes the the person being healed is
a part of the scam
and sometimes the person being healed is
sort of a victim
and and we've seen every scenario with
this okay sometimes it's an individual
who was never actually paralyzed for
example sometimes what can happen is
there's sort of like a surge of energy
there's like an endorphin release and
you might temporarily think you're
healed you know there's often like the
ones who I haven't walked in 40 years
and then they stand up and they push
their their cane away or their their
Walker or whatever and then it turns out
they weren't really healed they had like
a you know just a surge of energy and
they could have briefly stood at any
point but it doesn't mean that now they
they can walk or anything like that but
sometimes the person being healed is
just out and out part of the scam and
it's all a lie as as I'm sure you can
imagine and I continue to say show me a
single faith healer
who can regrow the amputated limb of an
individual
that would be something that is much
less ambiguous although you could
probably make a scam with that too right
I mean David Copperfield makes it look
like he splits people in half so you
could you probably could make someone
look like they're missing a limb and
then it grows back or whatever but you
understand what I'm saying do something
like that
um and then we might be able to talk
about it but this goes back a very long
time preachers who claim to have cured
people of afflictions and it's a Rowdy
sort of Revival style crowd and
sometimes people from the crowd are
called out sometimes symptoms are called
out and people volunteer themselves and
again you don't know if they're victims
or if they're scammers or whatever the
case may be and sometimes there's a
physical laying of hands on them
sometimes there isn't we've seen fake
surgery we've seen all all of this stuff
and of course there's no evidence that
any of it is miraculous and again we
could test this we really could you know
I'm going I'm going to tell you the way
it could be done and we all know that
these Faith healers would never subject
themselves to it but if you really
wanted to do this you could go to the
faith healers you could go okay listen
let's make it fair
give me the list of conditions you could
cure that you could heal none of them
would say I can regrow an amputated limb
that would never be there they'll go
well I can cure problems of the of the
stomach you know stomach pains I can
cure and headaches and tingling numbness
whatever get the get to actually get the
list from them of the stuff and then you
do a controlled experiment and then of
course we all know if any of these folks
could really do this stuff
it would be immediately
praised by the medical community it
would be studied and praised if it was
determined to be real now I know many of
you will say David the Western Medical
Community would never acknowledge Faith
healing because if Faith healing were
real they would be out of a job they
wouldn't need you wouldn't need doctors
anymore if Faith healing or real okay
yeah I understand the motivation claim
that you're making
but the Medical Science Community
studies everything you know people like
to say we we've never studied the effect
of giving people high doses of niacin
for depression actually we have studied
that there's many studies about that and
I guarantee you especially the medical
researchers that are not part of big
Pharma would be glad to evaluate and
study this and we would all know if it
were actually a real thing but they
never subject themselves to it so this
can be dangerous in that some people
accept it as an alternative to seeking
real medical treatment it's often
fraudulent
it often is weaponized against people
with little financial means so they're
there in the first place maybe because
they can pay 40 bucks to go into the
revival tent rather than what it might
cost for for real treatment and that's a
problem with the medical system of
course which we've talked about
uh but let's rely on evidence-based
medicine
um uh and I I don't know what else to
tell you but this is truly horrible
stuff
folks the Spanish channel is now live
the Spanish channel is now live we have
launched the David packman show in
Spanish or we might call it the David
packman show in espanol you can find
this new channel at YouTube now listen
very carefully here okay because
URLs can't contain that little that goes
above the n in some Spanish words so you
go to youtube.com slash
at symbol David packman
espanol not espanol
espanol okay I know it's the best we
could do with the URL
this channel
is our next project to reach Spanish
speaking American residents of course
everyone is free to watch one of the
things I hear all the time and
experienced personally when I did the
Spanish show around the time of the 2020
election is that there is a dearth
of progressive opinion content in
Spanish about American politics yeah in
Argentina you can find a thousand shows
about Argentinian politics in Mexico you
can find a thousand shows about Mexican
politics but so many of you write to me
and say David I'm first generation
second generation whatever I like
watching news and politics in English my
parents like watching in Spanish we need
something like the David Pacman show in
Spanish the right has tons of Spanish
language talk radio spreading conspiracy
theories about everything from vaccines
to Jews and everything in between okay
so the reason we're doing this and it's
not cheap is because it is necessary it
is necessary to do it so
tell people who prefer to consume
content in Spanish that this is now
available youtube.com slash at
davidpakman ESP
a-n-o-l okay if you want to help us just
by subscribing as well even if you're
not looking for the Spanish stuff great
we are under a thousand subscribers on
this but I think that this could be
absolutely huge and remember that we do
fund this entire project we have to pay
for the dubbing okay
we have to pay for that up front and
it's at a loss because obviously the
channel is just starting
the David Pacman show memberships do
fund all of the stuff that we're doing
including this new Spanish project which
I think is just so important it could be
so important to actually electing
Progressive candidates we need to be
reaching the Spanish-speaking audience
uh and it's an amazing thing to be doing
so super super exciting now one thing I
will mention people have already started
to write to me and they say David
you speak Spanish you should be just
doing this all of the segments over
again in Spanish I can't do it okay I'm
out of time for the day uh I I just do
not have the time between all of my
current responsibilities filming the
show
uh working with our team to get
everything out short form content live
streams running the business the baby at
home all these different things I can't
also now start doing my show in Spanish
so I know there are people who would
rather me do the Spanish language stuff
I it's just it exceeds the number of
hours in the day so that is not going to
be part of the plan but I think this is
a really great thing let's do it let's
check it out let me know what you think
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P
a few people contacted me about the
Circuit City stuff that came up during
my interview a couple weeks ago with
Patrick Bett David here's one such
voicemail
hey David I saw you on Patrick Bet
David's podcast yes and uh I know you
brought up uh how you sold the extended
service plans at Circuit City and I just
wanted to hear the story
um it sounds like you wanted to talk
tell it and he didn't really give you a
chance so
I was curious thanks well you know it's
not really one story but it was
absolutely you know I've said before
when I worked at Circuit City when I was
in high school it really allowed me to
develop really important interpersonal
skills
for quickly building Rapport
um establishing a connection with people
getting right to the Crux of whatever it
was that brought people into the store
that day really invaluable skills that
that I'm so grateful even if Circuit
City ultimately laid me off because they
laid off everybody who was selling too
much stuff because they didn't want to
pay us when they switched from
commission to hourly but one of the most
interesting aspects of it was the
selling of extended service plans and
I've said before that at Circuit City
if you were reliably selling these
service plans you could make half to
sixty percent of your income from the
service plans rather than the products
themselves it wasn't uncommon I'm going
back a ways now but just roughly it what
and think about inflation this was over
this was 20 years ago it wasn't uncommon
that if you sold a computer you might
make 18 in commission but the warranty
associated with it would pay you 40
bucks if the customer bought it and we
had all sorts of interesting techniques
and ideas and everybody always tried to
be creative but honest in order to sell
those service plans and we were not
incentivized to lie because if there was
a problem the people would come back
that service plan would be refunded and
you would lose the commission so there
really was not an incentive to lie one
of the things I would often do is
I would introduce the idea of the fact
that sometimes things break and it's
better to be able to come back to the
store than they have to ship it to you
know Hewlett Packard or whatever I would
introduce it early in the process and
that made it so that it sort of sold
itself so people would come in you know
they might be looking for a laptop and
say oh well what why are you looking for
the laptop my mind crapped out really
how old was it uh three years really and
did did you have an extended service
plan on it no I didn't oh you know if if
you did it might be covered you might
just be able to get it fixed that was my
Approach I wasn't coming up with any you
know confrontational techniques to start
begging people to buy warranties I would
just introduce it early and by the time
we would get to the sales point I would
say by the way
I mentioned earlier that if you had had
a service plan on your current laptop
you might not even need to get a new one
right now it's a relatively small amount
of money given how expensive computer
repairs are right now and you know at
the time it was much harder to work on
laptops than it is now so many of the
parts were self-contained and
proprietary here's what it is and it
really was was that symbol you know
there was no there was no big mystery to
it but it really was about establishing
the Rapport and building the
relationship with people anyway
it was a fascinating time and invaluable
in terms of uh the the skills that I
learned there and sadly Circuit City
decided no more commission we see Best
Buy paying people seven bucks an hour
let's switch everybody to hourly and
then within months was out it was out of
business Maybe not maybe like 18 months
or something along those lines uh so
apparently the the wrong decision so
that was the Circuit City story we have
a fantastic bonus show for you today oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money yes everybody else it makes money
to find themselves as bad let's make
some money Alex let's do it we are going
to talk about the reports that Nikki
Haley is reportedly about to announce
she's running for president in 2024
becoming the first what we might call
major competitor Donald Trump trump is
going to lose his mind Trump and Haley
were friendly during Trump's presidency
but this is going to trigger Trump and
it's going to be very interesting we'll
discuss that secondly Alabama Democrats
want to ban employers from being able to
force workers to get microchipped why is
this even coming up I will tell you and
lastly the College Board is slamming
desantises Florida for what it is
calling slander of the advanced
placement black history course that has
been the subject of so much controversy
over the last few weeks all of those
stories and more when I am joined by
producer at on today's bonus show sign
up at joinpakman.com don't miss it
because it is going to be a beautiful
bonus show I will see you next